14th and 15th century paintings revealed by Russia
prove that Jesus was not white,
but black. He,
his mother, and the people around him were all black.
That's a groundbreaking revelation,
questioning why Europe depicted Jesus as white until now.
So what have we found in the centuries old Russian cellars and vaults?
What people have been shown in the paintings found in these vaults
that completely change biblical teachings?
Let's know about that in this video.
Recently, news surfaced that Russian President Vladimir Putin
has ordered the relocation of one of Russia's most sacred icons
from a museum to a Moscow cathedral.
For centuries,
these paintings remained locked in vaults,
but now the world has the chance to observe them.
This fundamentally changes our understanding of Jesus,
his mother, and his disciples.
These paintings are called the Russian Icons,
which are collections of hundreds of paintings depicting Jesus era
and his life. In Russian icons,
Father Vladimir Evenov explores Russian iconography in depth,
offering insights into the history,
symbolism, and spiritual significance of these sacred artworks.
Authored by a distinguished expert in the field,
Father Ivanov
presents readers with a comprehensive overview of Russian iconography,
covering various aspects.
However, even if the artwork show various instances,
they have one similarity.
They show Jesus,
his mother, people and even angels as black.